brother did you see the minions movie no
i did not why not you didn't dress up in
a tuxedo nope
you don't believe in it nope do you
think it's the greatest movie role out
of all time yeah never been before ever
in history yeah it's never happened in
the history of the internet it's on blue
they're geniuses the way they did is
they're absolute geniuses the minions
are
also the media
just this idea like you understand that
all these kids watched the movie when
they were children now they are what are
they gen z's they're called
now they're these gen z's are you know
15 16 17 18 19 20s early 20s
how do you get those same people that
really enjoyed minions and minions had a
profound effect on their childhood to
tap into the movie again yeah you don't
have to teach them about the product
again and they definitely don't want to
watch a child movie like a movie only
for kids
so like tapping into yeet and creating
this like marketing plan like with the
memes and other stuff it was just genius
it's like you basically get them to feel
the nostalgia while also feeling the
relevance yeah and a really cool thing
it's not nostalgic pardon hip and
nostalgic
and a cool thing is happening it's like
with some of these marketing
like minions figure this out there's
something i realized when social media
came around it's not just quality of
content but because younger generations
uh get social currency by sharing things
yeah the thing that they share has to
then make them cool yeah as well like
everything is content to these kids so
for example going to minions and just
saying hey i went to the minion movie
isn't as cool as dressing up in an all
black suit yes and going to it yes
bringing bananas there and eating it
right so it's like
i think what the people that did the
marketing for this movie realize is the
kids need to feel in on the joke they're
not just
sharing like a nice piece of stand-up
because they're like this is really
funny yeah they have to almost like
something ironically
i think that's where a lot of things
grow it's like it starts as irony we're
actually kind of making fun of this
thing we don't really like it
and then all of a sudden i like it i
like it yeah here's this white rapper
kid that wears a turban it's kind of
about to like him and then all of a
sudden oh [ __ ] the music is kind of fire
yeah and then it's become a movement and
now you're down to be part of the
movement because you started it yeah
weirdly the kids need to be making fun
of the thing that they like yeah it's a
weird time to be a content creator too
but does it is it risky for the movie
franchise because now you turn this
movie into like a joke and so it becomes
like sharknado or some [ __ ] like that's
internet but i don't think if it's
especially because they already have
hits in the can
so now you're coming out with another
one new kid's probably going to look at
that like like a five-year-old's gonna
be like oh that's not for us
possibly that's you know whatever or
they'll just like it regardless i think
that five-year-old yeah
[Laughter]
it's an interesting time to be a content
creator because you got to get
five-year-olds who are very hip and with
it
i just feel like
i feel like it depends at this point on
the movie so if the movie itself is good
all those kids that went there
ironically will be like
i actually was kind of fire like you got
them in the door now it's up to you
deliver if you don't deliver that's a
one-time lick and you're right it's one
one and done trying to recreate it
people like i don't need to come back
but if you get them in the door and they
actually enjoyed the experience and
liked the characters and thought this
story was really cool
and you'll be able to look at nah not
watch time but you'll be able to look at
like the the word of mouth and how many
tickets are sold et cetera and see if
people actually like it and be like okay
we got something let's keep running it
up and you know what makes a lot more
sense than the organ i made earlier kids
don't care they're going to like it
regardless you just got to get the 15
year olds in when you say kids you mean
children yeah three four five they don't
care they don't know what's yeah but now
i think movie uh franchises are movie um
production houses are gonna keep doing
this type of thing oh and then now it's
gonna be like cheesy well also the
people getting the jobs for the
marketing grew up with the internet
whereas before because those kids are 25
now 26 27 before we didn't really grow
up in the internet so we're just kind of
guessing yeah now these guys are like
nah this is how you do it i grew up with
this
yeah we were talking about just the
special and i was and i was asking uh
the guys i was asking shub and i was
asking shifty and i was just like what
what what are the things
within your generation that have become
popular off of like merit off of like
the actual quality like obviously sports
you're popular if you score a lot of
points because
there's a there's a metric that shows
how good you are right but like what are
the the
the pieces of content that are just
purely oh this is brilliant
i have to give it up for this thing yeah
and it was very hard for them to come up
with ideas and i suggested euphoria and
they're like ah yeah euphoria like
people it's just kind of ubiquitous like
this is a great show and we like this
show but most of the things that they
were saying were popular were kind of
like jokes on top of jokes
that had to do with memes right right so
it was like a constant sarcasm or like a
meta approach to comedy and it's very
interesting because when creating
content do you want to create the thing
that's made fun of so that people spread
it like how do you tell which one came
first so i feel like one perpetuates the
other like yeah so i guess that's that
the question i was just uh posing was
are you playing into how kids share
things and then creating the thing that
is made fun of and then it's shared or
are you organically trying to make
something good and they're like this is
ridiculous and then they share it yeah i
mean i guess both happens all the time i
think they both do happen the thing is
how do you gain that system you know i
think when we were coming up it's and i
could be completely [ __ ] wrong it
could be the exact same thing but it
feels a little bit more like hey if you
make the really good thing
then people will see it
yeah or just cool wasn't it's cool
because we're all kind of laughing at it
then it becomes cool because we're all
kind of doing it mm-hmm it was just cool
like but we did have ironic things that
happened before and there's one that
i'll that i'll point out i wonder if it
was impactful for you guys
there was a time where mtv did a vj
competition yeah i remember that there
was the guy that they wanted yeah who
ended up working with mtv yeah i don't
know for a fact that they weren't dave
his name is dave and he ended up working
for the company being a vj and then went
on and it was good smooth there's
another guy who was a crackhead named
jesse and he was literally like a heroin
addict with a wild voice wild hair i
think he was even [ __ ] homeless like
some kind of like east village kid like
whatever
and jesse
was so cut he could barely read the
teleprompter the other guy was like
remember he was like polished and he had
the whole thing down repeat the line
the guy
but people we thought were like wouldn't
it be funny if the guy that should never
win they're leaving it up to us wouldn't
it be funny that i should never win win
and we had this minions-esque moment
where we were like let's
create satire here let's be ironic we're
going to ironically like the guy who's
not good at his job he is kind of
authentically unique in himself but he's
not and that movement there was no
internet think about that you're like
making phone calls to make this happen
imagine that with internet there's memes
about him you have the polished guy who
should get the job and the guy who
should never be paid to talk in front of
a camera right and that never be paid
talking before the camera guy wins
i remember him winning i don't remember
anything about him but i also don't
remember everybody being like oh this
guy let's just laugh at him yeah but the
difference between this and a minions is
you didn't eventually be like you know
what jesse's great dude he's so good i
love this guy i don't know that happened
you could tell me oh no i don't think i
don't think he ended up having like a
big career after it but and then that
was the kind of [ __ ] up thing it's
like immediately after it's just like
okay we're done with that cool adventure
it's like free brittany he's like free
britney was like kind of
ironic there are some people who
actually cared but most people didn't
really even look into her psychology
it's like oh this is a cool thing to be
a part of and it's almost like ironic
yeah free braiding we had fun with it we
made i wore a [ __ ] free britney shirt
on some pod i forget what it was
i forget maybe it was maybe it was on
stage i don't know but
it was like we're teasing this thing
i just hope that the younger generation
still has room to appreciate real
quality content
and uh i asked them like what's the
musician that people like they're like
drake and it was like okay
that they can't but they're not sharing
it close to as much as they are that
this guy that they can like ironically
drake might have been the gateway into
this thing though because drake we all
laughed at the fact that he was corny
but the music was undeniable no
the the corniness creates the room for
the ironic support
all the memes where he's like dancing
yeah like looking grassy he's wheelchair
jimmy whatever yeah
so it's almost like that needs to play a
part in it yeah but i remember the
baseline of it and i'm not discounting
what you're saying i'm saying i think
it's the gateway because in addition
a lot of people were like you call them
corny if you want to but the music
[ __ ] slaps that was the pushback i
would get as somebody who just didn't
really like him from the beginning you
can act like the music don't slap me
slaps music [ __ ] so that's where that
was there and then the memes and [ __ ]
like when he was dancing in the [ __ ]
used to call me on my cell phone
he was already [ __ ] huge at that
point yeah but then it became its own
like bang bang bang bang meme was like
like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't know i don't know but i don't
know what begets what because like the
reason why those memes are working is
because we all know it like it's
basically just like a digital inside
joke everyone's like oh we've seen this
meme i know this guy he has a funny face
here that he doesn't like something and
he has a face that he likes something
that's yeah yeah you know there's a line
in the office my wife loves the office
great show but she loves it so it's on a
lot and there's a line where like
michael scott's like the goofy guy that
nobody likes and he goes uh i love
inside jokes i'd love to be a part of
one someday and it's a funny line but
also that is essentially what you just
said is like yo how happy are we when
we're all a part of the inside joke yeah
and then we just share it and share it
and share it and then eventually it's
gonna catch everybody and if it's
quality you'll be like oh this is
actually dope though yeah yeah and then
you become a fan fan yeah so i think
drake realized that early on and he like
leaned into it like he took him
for people to meme him yeah he did the
power of the meme yeah and at first it
used to marketing ability i think that's
true because remember when he first came
out he was saying oh he looked like he
has down syndrome this kid is like super
emo yeah like canadian rapper
somehow he just looks like a sharpie
[Laughter]
starfish
like he leaned into it and now people
don't necessarily make fun of his like
actual character it's just like okay
we'll just make fun of when he actually
wants us to make fun of him yeah so now
everybody's gonna when i do the i'm too
sexy song or whatever it's like yeah
that's easy to me yeah he has a great
sense of humor about himself it seems i
didn't know about the beginning but like
it seems like he's willing to take a
joke and he makes fun of himself and
he's very like loose with it which is
incredibly likable when it's someone
that famous yeah because most famous
people i don't want to say i don't know
most but like the famous people that we
see that seem incredibly sensitive to
being teased or being positioned in a
weird way and like when you see somebody
that's that famous that successful
that's laughing at themselves you're
like oh wow are you like a real person
yeah you know now what were you saying
there was
yeah i guess like the
place where it gets hung up is like i
feel like if the brand or the person is
too self-aware
and like they
are perpetuating overhandedly the memes
you know what i mean like i feel like
drake does a good job like doing it
subtly whereas he'll like i'll do a song
and then people will just pick it up
organically because that's what people
do so like it can come across thirsty if
you're like too in on it yeah exactly or
if like he's the one that's like hey
guys we're doing a new challenge we're
doing the my song challenge it's like oh
it's not fun anymore because you're
telling me the inside joke well real
quick on this
i'm not teasing you
yeah yeah
you're too in on it yeah even if you
aren't gonna shut the [ __ ] up yeah let
them be the ones that do it because then
they're gonna get all the credit
if you're the one pushing your own dance
kiki challenge if shiggy doesn't push it
into a [ __ ] for that too yeah oh wait
wait like a little bit because it felt
forced it was like oh he's really trying
to get a tick tock song to blow and like
we were kind of knocking it at first
that kiki challenge yeah i think so i
think most people are like oh i thought
yeah i thought shiggy started it and it
blew up and then i saw [ __ ] sierra
doing it
the fact that he's has like the steps to
the dance in the song the twosies
i'm sorry i'm thinking of that yeah yeah
i think he thought to see slide and this
is so and that one he got pushed back
forward i think that's his point yeah i
think we made one of them we're like uh
you want the tick tock yes yeah but
ironically the one that blows up is the
one where shiggy shah sushi just does a
hilarious video in his [ __ ] sandals
outside of his house in queens and it
becomes like a dance dream yeah right
yeah and that is
the pureness and there's authenticity
and then drake leaned in and did a video
with shiggy and blah blah blah like he
let it become a thing then he was in on
it and then he's more likeable but that
that's i guess what's so impressive
about the minions movie is that it isn't
authentic right it isn't pure but is
done so well
that even the people that recognize
they're being marketed to
are allowing themselves to be marketed
to
and playing into the marketing and it
doesn't hurt the fact that
they they outlawed it and like people
are getting arrested for it because now
it looks bad so was that because that's
how i found out about is the kids
wearing the suits to the premiere was
that a planted thing or was that just
something that happened over here i
don't know who knows i don't know
because i think if that happened
organically that's how i found out about
it and that's how i was like oh this
movie seems fun yeah even as a 38 year
old man i'm like this seems fun
it's uh what is that [ __ ] that was by
where we lived uh our old place in these
villages where they dress up rocky
horror oh rocky horror picture show
right yeah and yeah it's fun to be on
the inside yeah yeah it's the inside
joke you're wearing the outfits you're
dressed up it's but it's fun to be
mischievous if minions is posted on
their instagram like hey guys we're all
dressing up in suits going on that's why
it's not machines yet yo if minions
really want to throw gas on it
hey guys please do us a favor yes yeah
don't wear the suits and move ears
because it's causing a lot of problems
people are very concerned and blah blah
yeah yeah out of here but that's how
they do it so like they link with cole
bennett the music video producer yes and
they're like yeah do the song with yeet
and like we'll give you rights to it but
we're not gonna promote it at all and so
you just meme it the way that you're
gonna do it to your audience the way
they're gonna like it but we i haven't
seen anything from them saying that they
acknowledge it and there's no post like
on there have you seen them have you
seen the music video this is the most
interesting part of it
it's there's not a single
shot in the music video that isn't in
the movie yeah it's just re-edited parts
of the movie yeah and i'm sure that was
a part of the deal that like okay you
can
do like the lyrical lemonade thing in
the braces when you open the minion
smiles at the very beginning but you
can't add anything else there's one
thing that they added they added
pictures of yeet as a minion
into like the polaroid pictures or
whatever but that's what movie
soundtrack is very subtle um music
videos used to be they would just have
mostly video and then snippets of the
movie like the [ __ ] diddy one forgot
godzilla it had like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was like kind of in the
movie setting but it wasn't it's mainly
diddy performing and then a little cut
to the movie this is the opposite it
flips it yeah barely any uh just regular
eat and the rest is just minions yeah
yeah it's just interesting i'm curious
what happens i'm curious like what type
of art comes out of this generation
and like how they develop a balance
between like irony and quality because
it needs to be quality for you to be in
on it i think that's one of the things
that and i don't know too much about
yeap but i think that's one of the
things that like sets them apart is that
like even though there was irony in
finding him the music had quality where
you enjoyed listening to it yeah so it's
like this random perfect combination
like yeah it's ironic to like the white
kid from [ __ ] seattle that wears a
turban yeah that's kind of like that
does rap music that's ironic and then
you listen to like hold on now
yeah right like how do you create that
how do you curate that how do you use
that type of marketing as like somebody
coming up that i don't know
yeah i don't know i just think he has to
be very subtle and like uh hands off in
a way yeah you can't force them they
have to create it themselves it has to
and then how do you inspire that without
having like um what are they called uh
plants or whatever yeah yeah i mean you
could do plants like i wouldn't call
like necessarily cold bends collab like
a plant but like you know like an
affiliate marketing thing and then like
they let happen and they recognize
people that are talented that are making
stuff that is moving culture yeah but
then they just say do it the way you
want to do it to me i'm like that's the
future of marketing that
if brands want to be smart about they
just let creators do whatever they want
to do with the things that they want
them to push but tapping into the
creators that already have a
stranglehold on
a group or culture yeah but like if cole
bennett's like hey guys come out to
watch this
make a fun do it the way you're going to
do it that's what i mean anytime we talk
to you know brands that we're working
with right it's just like
you
if you let us
do it honestly
it will be way more impactful yes
beyonce gets so i can't even imagine how
many millions from pepsi to do a super
bowl ad then they pay for the ad itself
then they pay for the air time imagine
they just threw beyonce half of that
total money and we're like do whatever
you want make it yours a whole different
i think it hits harder i think it saves
them money i think it makes the creator
more money i think in every way would be
more effective yeah it's so funny it's
like
once
once
brands or
corporations figure out how to do this
model
and i think maybe we touched on this
earlier but like
the model will only list
last for like a couple years
like once it becomes obvious that every
pixar movie is tapping into the cool
musician and having them make the bit
like literally hollywood is a race to be
second so right now there is a cartoon
coming out they're like we need a song
with yes future we need a song with blah
blah blah cardi's gonna do a thing yeah
yeah literally playboy how do we get
playwright card he'd be in the new
dracula movie he'll do the thing and
it's like and then like you said earlier
we'll notice that we're being
like marketed to
and then we'll reject the marketing